so first off how is isolation going for
you you look good thanks man thanks man
it's not bad you know be in LA the
weather's nice at least you know and
things are things are spread out far
enough that you can go for walks and
stuff and not be in contact with anyone
so it's good man I can't complain it's
it's a beautiful city so now I saw you
posted your four moods of isolation on
Instagram which one am I getting today
this is a different one probably the one
by the window looking out because the
weather is nice today so I'll probably
I'll probably stare out into the into
the blank abyss for run this town is out
on a video-on-demand and really
streaming services and VOD is what is
getting so many people through
self-isolation
what do you what do they need to know
about this movie anybody who's not
familiar with it you know it's it's
about the notorious Rob Ford scandal
that happened a few years ago him doing
crack cocaine and and you know saying
some very vulgar things about women but
basically it really focuses on the
Millennials that were behind this story
the reaction to the the original sort of
when we all knew that this movie was
happening right there was a complete
mixed reaction everybody wanted to know
what Doug Ford was gonna say people
didn't really know how to take it
because the story had changed now that
people have seen it and it is available
on video on demand what was the reaction
and how were you with the reaction it
was pretty positive you know I think
from Canadians especially I think as
Canadians we just want to see Canadians
stories being told there's just we have
so much history and so much culture in
Canada and it's just not depicted enough
on screen so you know especially in
Toronto I think it was very positive
people just liked seeing the story I
think the one thing people have to
understand is that these are real events
but fictional characters right so
you know you don't want to so much watch
the film and overanalyze it and say well
was this character real was this
character real other than Rob Ford the
characters are fictional but the events
that occur are true and has Doug
commented on it at all not to me not to
my knowledge
now I know that Nina because I've talked
to her so many times she always is a bit
of a prankster on set did anything
happen on set that maybe we don't know
about with her with Nina no I mean she
didn't try to prank or anything we had a
really good time we shot most of our
stuff together and obviously we went
around all of Toronto shooting so we
shot at the Thompson hotel right outside
of Thompson hotel and by the CN Tower
and everything and she had her her dog
maverick with her so that was cool you
guys had a really good time right we did
we had a great time and I was looking
forward to working with her I was a fan
of hers for a long time and so what was
that what's that like because I mean I'm
sure that it's with Nina it's not the
first time this has happened you being a
fan of somebody growing up and then
getting a chance to work with them are
you checking people off your list and
who's still on your list I am I am you
know it's the craziest thing before I
booked Jack Ryan I had just been to the
office for you know for the very first
time and I was just thinking you know
how incredible these actors are John
Krasinski Mindy Kaling Steve Carell I
mean you look back at that cast just act
and next thing you know you know I moved
to LA and got the chance to work with
with John Krasinski so that's happened
you know obviously Will Smith or Nina
Dobrev Damian Lewis you know is I Damien
doesn't have a lot of scenes with a lot
of different people in the film so I got
to spend a lot of time with him perform
with him so I've been blessed man worked
with some really really cool people have
you had a chance to catch Jon's good
news I was told about it
day actually in an interview I did so
yeah I checked it out on Instagram it
integrate man I love it I love that idea
so if you had let's go to aladdin right
now so if you had three wishes but you
can't say one of my wishes is to end
Cove at 19 or get out of the house but
if you had three wishes to change your
life inside self-isolation what would
you inside self-isolation I wish to see
all the films that got postponed you
know in my house that would be cool you
know if I can you know see all these
films what else I wish I'd wish to have
unlimited groceries so I don't have to
deal with going to the grocery store
right and what else and you know what
I'd wish to have a voiceover studio that
would be cool which I could probably do
but it would cost me some a pretty penny
to set up a set up of voice studios but
yeah I don't know that'd be cool just
get laying down some accents and voice
work and and you know I'm surprised I'm
not sure this answer but I think voice
actors may still be working because a
lot of them just record from their own
homes yeah so I so everything now is the
content that people are going with I
don't know if did you see the Disney
sing-along that happened last week I
didn't know you are week is there a
chance that we could get an Aladdin
sing-along like really you guys are
sitting around doing nothing like what
is like like what's will doing right now
we could do this why not yeah we could I
am get you know this is the first place
I'm announcing it but actually in May
I'm gonna have a watch party because
there it'll be a year since Aladdin came
out so I am gonna do a watch party with
my fans for a lot and so you're you're
thinking on the right track yeah that's
amazing what's this I hope you haven't
figured it out yet I haven't told
anybody yet okay but but it is details
are coming soon yeah okay so it's going
to be you while watching Aladdin with
fans watching you watch
I guess I think that's how a watch party
works yeah I'll try to get some other
people involved you know I'll probably
try to get Naomi and will involved but
we'll see you know we'll see that's
amazing
do you have like when you're there I
know LA right now it's it's paradise but
when you're there especially at a time
like this what do you miss about home
because I'm sure that life would be a
little bit different if you were self
isolating back in Toronto is there stuff
you miss about your life inside here in
Toronto I mean yeah this this time in
Toronto the weather's starting to get
nice the parks are starting to get full
you know you can walk around from one
end of the city to the other I love that
about it la even when you know the
weather's beautiful but even in LA you
you can't walk anywhere so so yeah
there's lots of things I miss about
Toronto
how is it there I gotta ask you okay are
people walking around the streets yeah I
will say this the weather here has been
crazy today
no joke I was outside of one poi and the
Sun was hitting me and I started to
sweat a little I came into the office I
went back in the living room looked at
the window and it was snowing no joke
like I know everything in show business
is shut down right now and nothing is
moving which has to be a level of
frustration for you because they've
announced Aladdin too and I know that
you hadn't heard anything so now that
nothing is moving
are you like have you stopped looking at
your phone now just simply because show
business has effectively shut down
completely um I have been off my phone
you know a lot like it I've actually
been enjoying how much I've been off my
phone I haven't been as active on social
media but honestly I mean actors actors
are used to being in between jobs anyway
and you know you have nothing going on
and you have everything going on so I'm
kind of used to this I think maybe in a
couple of weeks it'll start feeling a
little weird but even my normal life you
know I've gone you know I've gone a
couple of months without
working just going to the gym and stuff
that's it so I'm kind of used to this
more than most people are I guess a lot
of actors are sure and and with that
with everything shut down now I imagine
there's projects that you had on the go
or there's things that you had expected
to be upcoming and now that everything
is getting pushed how messed up is your
schedule going to be in six months you
know honestly I'm gonna be honest with
you with me we were still trying to
figure stuff out we were still trying to
figure out what my next move is and what
my next job is so my schedule isn't so
much messed up I imagine you know actors
who are really busy like will you know
like John Krasinski all these people
that we just talked about you know
they're probably gonna be backed up for
the next couple years but for me I'm
honestly hoping that it just gets really
busy and then we can start lining stuff
up right and if you can recommend a few
movies that have helped you get through
this - fans what would they be you got
to get on Tarantino I mean this is a
great time to just binge Tarantino like
watch all his movies Paul Thomas
Anderson's films go check those out you
know these are directors that I guess
Tarantino's mainstream now but Paul
Thomas Anderson
you know Wes Anderson even try to watch
films that you aren't used to watching
so there will be blood you know check
out Jackie Brown check out Kill Bill
both films you know there's lots of good
stuff out there now in between all those
is it okay to catch a few episodes of
too hot to handle it's good to talk to
you you look like you're doing great
when's the cookbook out September 15th
as of right now but obviously because we
are gonna plan a book tour before it you
know I'm gonna be traveling over the
United States and Canada that may get
pushed but as of right now
Simon & Schuster's releasing the book
September 15th wonderful it's good to
see you again and we'll talk brother you
got it alright good seeing you man good
to see you here